death is as commonplace in film as green
screens and fake facial hair but in some
cases there's a lot of confusion
surrounding the death of a character
from mysterious disappearances to
off-screen mortalities these movie
deaths were never truly explained
in indiana jones in the kingdom of the
crystal skull sean connery didn't return
as professor henry jones though he'd
proven a welcome addition to the indie
franchise and indiana jones in the last
crusade
dad oh dad ah dad
head for the fireplace we don't get a
lot of information on how professor
jones died but indy confirms it in
kingdom of the crystal skull while
looking at a photograph of his father on
his desk
we're apparently meant to assume henry
died of natural causes but the events of
the last crusade beg for a more specific
explanation
in the film the villainous walter
donovan shoots indy's father leaving the
holy grail as henry's only possible
salvation
indie finds the grail heals henry's
wound with it and has him drink from the
cup
earlier in the movie we're told that the
knights who discovered the grail were
alive 150 years after finding it
meaning the artifact bestows longer life
taking one little drink might not grant
henry 150 more years but it seems
reasonable to assume it'd give him at
least a little more time than expected
perhaps off screen he went on another
adventure with indy that he shouldn't
have
sean connery's henry jones isn't the
only elder academic missing from indiana
jones in the kingdom of the crystal
skull
museum curator and martial college dean
of students marcus brody is missing as
well though the real life reason for his
absence was incredibly tragic
dan home elliott the actor who played
brody and raiders of the lost ark and
indiana jones on the last crusade
sadly passed away in 1992 from
aids-related tuberculosis
it's never mentioned exactly how marcus
dies in indy's narrative but he isn't
forgotten in kingdom of the crystal
skull
after marcus's passing a statue is
erected in his honor on the campus of
marshall college
when india and mutt lead kgb agents on a
chase through the campus one of the cars
crashes into brody's memorial bust
that's when the head of the statue
breaks off crashes through the car's
windshield and lands in the lap of one
of the kgb agents
the autobot known as sightswipe isn't
the most visible transformer
he makes his first appearance in
transformers revenge of the fallen
showing up in shanghai where he kills
the decepticon
sideways sideswipe returns and
transformers dark of the moon and while
he survives the second film he's absent
in both transformers age of extinction
and transformers the last knight
we don't see him killed or hear anything
about why he isn't around anymore
believe it or not the minor hero's death
is revealed not on the big screen or
even at a behind-the-scenes feature but
on a collectible trading card that
reveals he was killed between movies
of course if it's only explained in a
trading card set that means a lot of
viewers who only know him from the
movies can imagine sideswipe is still
out there somewhere
one of the most confusing
non-explanation explanations for death
comes in the conclusion to the star wars
prequels with 2005's revenge of the sith
while anakin skywalker is being turned
into a slow breathing cyborg his
clandestine wife padme amidala dies for
extremely vague reasons
after giving birth to twins padme
appears to be in perfect health
nevertheless her life is still slipping
away so why is she dying
well as a medical droid explains the
obi-wan kenobi we don't know why she's
lost the will to live
even if we forget for a moment that
deeming a person to have lost the will
to live
seems a fairly deep revelation for a
droid we're left with two sentences that
literally contradict one another
the droid first says it doesn't know why
she's dying then it says why
she's dying it would be as if it said we
don't know why she's dying
also she was decapitated still she lost
the will to live
isn't much of an explanation we can dig
deeper ourselves and theorize that it's
because anakin broke her heart with his
betrayal so she just didn't want to live
anymore that said she also knew she had
twin babies on the way which seems like
something worth living for
so the real medical explanation for
exactly why padme died might remain a
mystery forever
after the tv series twin peaks was
canceled the prequel film twin peaks
fire walk with me was released in 1992
the film opens on the investigation into
the death of teresa banks conducted by
agent chet desmond and his partner agent
stanley
their investigation abruptly ends in the
fat trout trailer park when agent
desmond discovers the victim's ring
under
a trailer we see him reach for it and
that's it we never see him again
it could be that desmond isn't dead
instead he may have been pulled into an
otherworldly place known as the black
lodge the original tv series ends when
agent dale cooper is imprisoned there
and in fire walk with me when cooper
investigates desmond's disappearance
he finds the words let's rock written
across the windshield of desmond's car
a phrase spoken in the tv series by a
black lodge resident
a mysterious man from another place
in spite of the series getting a second
lease on life and 2017's twin peaks to
return desmond's fate isn't mentioned
in an ama reddit session after the
mini-series concluded co-creator mark
frost apologetically told fans that even
though the character was discussed the
showrunners couldn't come up with a way
to bring desmond back quote from
wherever he is
if all you know of jack crawford comes
from the award-winning 1991 film the
silence of the lambs and you might not
think he's a very important character to
the franchise
but crawford is integral to the thomas
harris novels that the movies are based
upon and scott glenn plays him to
perfection in the first film
however crawford fails to appear in the
2001 sequel hannibal
in fact he isn't mentioned at all in the
film's theatrical release
a deleted scene confirms he died before
the film's events but it doesn't mention
how
in the novel hannibal crawford dies from
a heart attack but this happens during
the events of the book
not before in 2015 glenn told the av
club both he and silence of the lamb's
co-star jody foster were asked to return
for hannibal but they agreed doing so
could quote
ruin a good thing so both declined still
it's unfortunate director ridley scott
was either unwilling or unable to recast
the role or at least make some room in
the screenplay to explain why crawford
wasn't around in the theatrical release
of course glenn is now part of a rich
tradition of acclaimed actors playing
jack crawford in 2002
harvey keitel took the role of crawford
and the prequel red dragon and lawrence
fishburn played him in the acclaimed
hannibal tv series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one